PROFESSOR: Hi there.
My name is Ana.
Welcome to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about how to multiply matrices,
and how to think about
that multiplication
in different ways, and
also about when a matrix is
invertible or not, and how
to compute the inverse when
it is invertible.
And that's what today's
problem is about.
We have a matrix A that
has variables a and b
instead of numbers.
And the question is: what are
the conditions on a and b that
make that matrix invertible?
And when it is invertible,
what is A inverse?
Why don't you hit Pause and
work on it for a little while.
And then we'll come back
and work on it together.
And we're back.
I hope you had success
in solving that.
Let's do it ourselves.
So, remember from
lecture, we talked
about-- well,
Professor Strang talked
about how it's easy to spot--
some easy tests to spot when
a matrix is not invertible.
Those were: if you have a column
of 0's or a row of 0's, then
the matrix is not invertible.
Or if you have two
columns that are the same,
or two rows that are
the same, the matrix
is also not invertible.
So let's see if this
matrix satisfies
any of those easy conditions.
Well, here you
have a row of a's.
If a is equal to 0, you have
a row of 0's, the matrix
is not invertible.
So a is-- What
was the other one?
Two of the same column
or of the same row.
Well, if a is equal to b, then
all the entries in the matrix
are the same, so all
the rows are the same,
all the columns are the same,
the matrix is not invertible.
So that's the other
easy condition.
A is not invertible if a is
equal to 0 or a equals to b.
There's not any other easy
condition that I can spot.
So we have to do it in
a more systematic way.
So to do that, actually what
we do is we start with A,
we try to find its inverse,
and if in the process
we run into something fishy,
those are our conditions.
So remember how to find
the inverse of a matrix?
You start by writing a
giant matrix that has
A and the identity next to it.
And then you perform
elimination steps
until-- let's put dots here,
because there's lots of steps--
and you stop once you've
reached the identity
matrix on the left side.
And when you do that, what
you have on the right side
will be your A inverse.
Easy enough.
So let's do the computations.
a, b, b; a, a, b; a, a, a; and
my identity matrix next to it.
And now I know you
learned about elimination
in the past recitation.
So I'll do the first
few steps slowly,
and then I'll just write the
solution for the last steps.
So we want to eliminate this a.
We want to turn it into 0.
So let's subtract the
first row from the second.
Let's do row 2 minus row 1,
and write it instead of row 2.
So a, b, b, 1, 0,
0; 0, so a minus a,
a minus b, b minus b is 0, 0
minus 1, 1 minus 0, 0 minus 0.
And then we want to do the
same with the third row.
So let's do row 3 minus row 1.
0, a minus b, it doesn't fit.
a minus b.
Can you understand that?
And then 0 minus 1,
0 minus 0, 1 minus 0.
All right.
Let's continue up here.
Now I want to eliminate
this a minus b.
I want to turn it into a 0.
So the first row stays the same.
a, b, b, 1, 0, 0; 0, a
minus b, 0, -1, 1, 0.
And now 0 minus 0, a minus
b minus a minus b is 0.
a minus b minus 0, that's easy.
-1 minus -1, 0 again.
-1 and 1.
Almost there.
We already have 0's down here.
It's looking more and more
like the identity matrix.
So we have to turn all these
diagonal entries into 1's, so
let's do that now.
1, b over a, b over-- oh.
I'm dividing by a.
a better not be 0.
Let me signal that here.
a different from 0.
1 over a, 0, 0.
0.
I want to make that into a 1.
So 1 over a minus b, and--
you guessed it-- a minus
b has to be different from 0.
0.
-1 over a minus b.
1 over a minus b.
0, 0, 1, 0, -1 over a minus b.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Someone's
pointing a mistake.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the (2, 2)
entry, you should have a 1.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're
absolutely right.
Thank you.
All right.
So not much left to do.
We only have to eliminate
b over a and b over a.
That's a little bit
computationally heavy.
So what do you have to do?
You just have to
basically subtract--
replace row 1 by row 1 minus b
over a times row 2 plus row 3.
Let me write that down.
row 1 minus b over a
times row 2 plus row 3.
You want that to
go into your row 1.
These stay the same.
-1 over a minus b.
1 over a minus b.
This is where I'm
going to go to my notes
and tell you that these
numbers are 1 over a minus
b, 0 minus b over a, a minus b.
That looks pretty awful.
But that is A inverse.
And we're done.
Except it looks terrible.
So let me just write
it in a nicer way.
A inverse equals-- see,
you're dividing everything
by a minus b, so
pull out that factor.
1, 0, minus b over a;
-1, 1, 0; 0, -1, 1.
Looks much better now.
So here's your A inverse.
And the other question was: what
are the conditions on a and b
for the matrix A
to be invertible?
Well, a has to be non-zero, and
a has to be different from b.
And we're done.
That's it for today.
See you next time.